everybody spends a lot of time in debate
prep that's part of running for
president even you did as a new
candidate right
uh and so you get used to what uh what
might come up and you think about what's
the smartest way to say it or just you
know this
suavest way to say it uh and for me as a
political reporter
what i'm always interested in is how do
people respond when you throw a question
at them that they're not expecting at
all
like how do you see the thought process
yes i think that's one reason why people
were attracted to me in my campaign is
they like the process
they liked and the fact that half the
time i actually was answering with an
original thought because i had not
figured out what the uh politically
honed answer was
right no i mean i i mean i do think that
that's what it was i think that you see
the people who were you know
all everybody always spends a lot of
time in debate prep and it's so obvious
almost all the time to the reporters and
to the voters
uh that these are the prepared
responses i think your campaign and
buddha judges campaign
are the ones that were most successful
in doing things in a very different way
from what anybody ever would have
thought possible
[Music]
welcome back to yang speaks this is your
co-host
zach grauman and a happy fourth of july
to everyone listening hope you're
enjoying some time with family and
friends before we introduce our speaker
our guest speaker today
edward isaac devere is joining one of my
favorite reporters for that a couple
housekeeping updates for y'all
just as we head into the summer so
what's going to happen
this fall we have some big things
planned for yank speaks now i hate when
people say there's big things coming and
then the big thing comes is not that big
and so maybe it's not that big in your
eyes but i'm pretty excited about what
we're doing this fall
but in the meantime we i want to give
you all the summer plan what's going to
happen
andrew's going to be hosting an episode
every monday as usual you will not miss
andrew yang on mondays it will be
more reactive to current events and also
having some awesome guests
sort of what you've been used to before
he was running for mayor which is
exciting
and on thursdays carly riley will be
joining us
to basically give our her takes on the
week because you all seem to love her
um both in terms of remember you
downloading a number of you interacting
with her takes so we're gonna have her
on
this summer before we launch our um kind
of our bigger stuff
uh that we're working on but it's
exciting to have her so she'll be on
with me every thursday and yang will be
doing his mondays so mondays and
thursdays on yank speaks that doesn't
change but the content will
i think you guys gonna love both of it
we're gonna try and give a good flavor
for every type of episode you don't want
to miss it and right now edward
isaac dover one of my favorite basically
we keep bringing our favorite
journalists from the presidential race
onto this podcast edward is
one of the best in the biz was he grew
up covering
and kind of cut his teeth covering new
york city politics and he's just wrote a
book on the
2020 election which andrew and many of
the candidates are featured prominently
he's a great guy he's hilarious and has
a fun perspective we love the guy
edward isaac dover joins yang speaks
right now
[Music]
[Applause]
it is my pleasure to welcome to yang
speaks one of the finest political
journalists in
all the land author of the new book
battle for the soul
isaac duver isaac welcome hey thanks for
having me i this is a historic moment
for the promotion of the book because
this is the first time that somebody
who's a main figure in the book
uh has invited me on to his podcast so i
appreciate it
isaac calling me a main figure is
is slightly misleading having read the
book this book could have used more
andrea
no no four people who like and support
me they're i do show up i do show up
so uh no no they're calling me a lead
figure possibly
uh i mean i i guess it's fair to say
that in the the book is 500 pages and
that was with
um significant cutting that we did uh
because we needed to make space for
the it was the final draft or the
the final version of the first draft was
supposed to be submitted on january 4th
uh and then we had to make some changes
to the book with things that happened
over the course of that week
um i sent an email to my book editor the
morning of january 4th that monday
and i said look here's the last chapters
except for the final chapter
because hey let's see what happens with
these georgia senate races and
uh on wednesday is going to be the
certification of the vote it's probably
gonna be a lot of political theater but
we have to account for it
and then uh i thought i might speak to
biden for it
uh for the book that first week in
january i ended up speaking to him for
the book but it wasn't until the
beginning of february
and so the last 50 pages of the book
were not uh
even planned until after it was supposed
to be done uh which
i'm sure you can from your own book
writing experiences
for count how how odd that is the
situation to be in but
that meant that we had to let go some of
the other material
uh cutting room floor i thought books
the glory of books is that you can just
keep on making them longer the original
conception of the book
did not which i started working on in
2018 it did not account for
2020 being quite as crazy a year as it
was um
i thought that the craziness would kind
of
taper off after the nomination process
was done
and at most maybe there'd be a long
fight for the the
nomination between two or maybe three
people
uh i obviously didn't anticipate the
pandemic or any of them
what that brought or any of the george
floyd aftermath
um or even uh ruth bader ginsburg dying
six weeks before the election and the
supreme court confirmation being in the
middle of this
uh so uh i i think that there's probably
a version of this book that could have
been
a thousand pages long but 500 seem like
enough
well i i have to say it is staggering
how much is
in the book like you you feel almost
like an omniscient narrator
uh which is you know insane given that
you're talking about
conversations that are had uh between
candidates and their staff
i was blown away by the level of detail
but i want to rewind a little bit so
people have a sense of
who you are and how you came to
to have the capacity to write this kind
of book so here's what i know you ran
for student body president
in new york city
[Laughter]
that's true and lost to your former
campaign manager chris coffee that's
true
yes and and then you became a
high-level new york journalist and then
became a high-level dc journalist
you and i met when you were covering the
presidential race
in iowa and then new hampshire uh but
how the heck does someone become
you like it seems impossible and i now
know
enough to know that there are only a
very small handful
of political journalists with your level
of stature and
access uh and authority uh if if people
want to find your writings uh i
associate you with the atlantic most of
all
uh that's where i i find most your stuff
um but how how how did your own path
evolve i mean you were
clearly somewhat into politics when you
were young
yeah uh well uh first of all it's nice
of what
to say what you did uh the path is sort
of a weird one
i was always interested in writing uh
and
found it appealing i was always
interested in politics uh
but uh it more is sort of like a
thing that i paid attention to um i was
never much of a sports fan so
it was politics instead which i guess
certifies me as a nerd in a deep way
and i never put the two pieces of it
together
even though i was uh in high school and
college
doing stuff like working on the school
newspaper and
that sort of stuff and and interning in
the senate
and in the house for
my local congressman um was jerry nadler
still there um and interned opening mail
uh for uh pat moynihan when he was his
last year in the senate uh and then
[Music]
uh through a roundabout way someone said
to me
hey uh i know uh
someone at the hill newspaper uh which
is still around now is very different
thing from what it was then it used to
come out once a week
um this was uh the spring of 2000 this
conversation happened
uh and uh the person said would you be
interested you're doing all this stuff
on like campus journalism would you be
interested in going to work there and
you could
uh do some stuff about politics and i
said sure mostly because it was already
probably march or april of that year and
i had not figured out my summer plans
um i got a very
helpful grant from uh where i was at
school at johns hopkins to
pay for me to have an unpaid internship
they
basically gave me the money that i would
earn if i had had a job and i went to
work there in 2000
and again it came out once a week and i
threw myself into whatever i could
uh and uh at the end of the summer was
the
were the two conventions and that year
it was the republicans in philadelphia
and the democrats in los angeles and i
said would you let me go cover them and
they said sure if you pay for it
and so um i did not go to los angeles uh
but i could figure out how to take the
train back and forth between
philadelphia
uh and i was still living in baltimore
for uh i had my apartment from hopkins
uh and so they got me passes to go and
it was a really fun time
and a lot of really cool coverage and i
got to like
interview uh bob dole at one point
and uh and henry kissinger and
i there was a not a
it was like a protest that got a little
dicey but not very dicey at all uh
outside uh not outside the conventional
drive more in
center city philadelphia i covered that
and it was so much fun that i went back
and i entered there the next year
um again at the hill um and that then
they kind of gave me my own
beat to do uh and because who comes back
and does an unpaid internship two years
in a row
um and you do very nice
i guess so uh and
then i um again
this certifies me even more as a nerd
everyone that i knew in grad in college
was applying to graduate school
so i had the peer pressure to apply to
phd programs and i got into none of them
but i got instead
i got into a master's program the phd
program rejected me and sent my
info to this master's program this was
all the university of chicago
for a program that was supposed to be
like okay this will get you more ready
to be in a phd program and when i did
that for a year
um and it was the year it was 0203
and it was
after september 11th it was when we were
sort of building up to go invade iraq
and it was really jarring to me to be so
far
in academia and not in what was going on
and the world was churning and
i grew up in new york and thinking about
all this stuff um
it just felt weird to be away from it so
i almost dropped out of that program but
it was a one-year program and i'd
already paid so i decided to stick with
it
moved back to new york and then got
involved in community journalism
uh covering community boards and uh
and local races city council races
um surrogate court races in
um and then
uh in 2006 the president the company
that i was working for said
hey i had this crazy idea a couple years
ago to start
a publication that would just be like
the hill but about new york politics
uh would you want to do it and i said
sure
um and i don't think he was really
taking it seriously but i brought him a
plan
a month later for how to do it so the
big lesson here is if somebody says to
you
would you ever want to do this and show
up with a plan um
and because when i did he said to me
okay let's try it
and so it's called city hall and we did
that came out
once a month eventually it was twice a
month
after about a year and a half we started
a companion one that was called the
capital which is about state politics
and i did that through 2011 and then uh
politico at that point was doing a bunch
of recruiting out of new york and they
recruited me
and i moved to washington to cover
national politics started out as an
editor of politico but moved back into
reporting
relatively quickly covered the obama
white house
through the second term was covering it
expecting that hillary clinton was going
to be the president as i think most
people were
including hillary clinton and donald
trump uh and
uh a lot of plans changed after
election night 2016. i stayed at
politico for about a year and a half
after that
um covering more national politics not
wanting to cover the trump white house
because i wanted to cover the bigger
things that were happening in politics
uh
which were already clear to me were
pretty significant and then moved over
to the atlantic in the
fall of 2018 and have been there since
and
wrote this book along the way i feel
like the atlantic
uh the schedule must be very different
because i feel like
like how often do you produce something
for the atlantic whereas the politico i
feel like there's like a
there there must have been a lot more
like of a
rhythmic cadence where it's like all
right gotta i gotta do this gotta do
that whereas i feel like atlantic lets
you bake things is that correct i'm not
sure yeah i mean i think it depends on
the situation and i think obviously in
the heat of the presidential campaign
uh news was happening much more quickly
for the campaign and now
uh it's not as much uh and
and so some of the things that i've done
recently there's a piece i wrote on you
about your mayoral candidacy that ended
up
baking actually a little bit longer than
we were expecting to but that was like a
three week turnaround and then there are
things that also still
sometimes uh there's something i wrote
actually also about new york politics
uh in march when uh
there was that rush of a time it seemed
like andrew cuomo was gonna have to
resign
and everybody was thinking that and it
became clear to me from conversations
that i was having
he was not going to resign he was not
going anywhere
and i wrote a piece that was on a very
very fast turnaround
uh for that and i think that went up 16
hours after i had first conceived of it
so but even that sometimes in politico
there would be
you did have to learn at politico to
have something happen and then have it
be on the website
maybe 90 minutes later at most um
sometimes
10 minutes later that's my feeling i
feel like politico is very
responsive and they do some other stuff
too whereas i i feel like
the atlantic the time frame's a little
longer so it sounds like you went to the
atlantic around 2018 and is that
when the thinking around this book also
came to to pass
when did you know this book was going to
exist so i wrote an article
for politico magazine uh that published
the day before trump's inauguration
that the the headline and it was uh
democrats in the wilderness and it was
okay that was a disaster for the
democrats
uh what happens now what's the possible
path back
and obviously there were a lot of people
asking that question
uh and sarah was clearly andrew yang
isaac
why was that not at the the forefront of
that article
in january 2017. in there there's some
conversation about
like what do we do about the economy and
the changing economy and
and like do you how do democrats address
that in a way
things that in the end obviously gave
you space for your
ideas to be resonant with people um were
there
um the other thing that i think was
there and as it relates to your campaign
and i'm not saying that's just because
i'm talking to you but um there there
was this question of authenticity which
was a real
weird one when donald trump is obviously
not
like the man of the people he uh has
lived a life that
uh has been very cloistered and uh
it's not within an ivory tower it's
within a golden tower right uh
and he uh but people felt like he was
authentic like he really said what he
meant
and democrats were really struggling
with that what that looks like and i
i think that part of what made
your candidacy appealing and by the way
like the buddha judge's candidacy
appealing was
the sense that like what if people just
kind of said what they were
thinking and were more who they were
even if it doesn't
fit at all the mold of what a
presidential candidate should look like
right um and that played out in
different ways too better o'rourke was a
good example of that obviously
uh not as successful uh in
the presidential campaign as he uh and
others thought he was going to be
uh but to come back to it so so i wrote
that article
and publishes in january 2017
it sparked a lot of interest from a lot
of people a lot of forlorn
democrats mostly uh and
uh i spoke with a couple of book agents
about it and originally there was a
conception that i should write a book
where the trump's election was almost
the end of it
um that's like how how it got to such a
bad place for democrats
and i was pushing back on that because i
said look i'm a journalist like i don't
think i want to write
just like a book that will end so far in
the past right
uh even if it had come out two years ago
it seemed to be more about
figuring out how to cover what was going
on the craziness that was happening
and i bounced around a couple of ways to
do it and finally
in the spring of 2018
uh in about march i said to my book
agent
you know um this book proposal that
we've worked on i think it's
it's not really interesting to me to
read it or let alone to write the book
that would be based off of it
um you should definitely switch gears
right
here um and she said what do you think
and i said well
look i think that you're going to have
a lot of people running for president on
the democratic side and it seems to me
like
there's going to be representation of a
lot of different
elements of the campaign of what's going
on
in the party within the campaign and so
you'll have
like the progressives with sanders and
warren or
and by the way at that point i think
most people including me assume that it
would only be one of them running
um that you'd have uh biden probably
running and that's the more traditional
thing you'd have
uh a bunch of women running you'd have a
bunch of people of color running you
know and
all these different things that would be
the way to tell the story
of what was happening in the party would
not be just this dry
sort of like policy recounting but tell
it through these people
right tell about like what it is to run
for president and how
and do these ideas connect with people
and which one
wins out and so i signed the book
contract in the summer of 2018.
it was before i moved over to the
atlantic but by the time that i moved
over to the by the time that i was
having the conversations with them about
moving over i knew that the book was
happening
and then and they knew it was happening
and they knew that part of the deal was
going to be
that i uh i would be working on the book
and
doing some reporting that would be only
for the book
and i think the balance worked out
pretty well and the book
reads i hope like a lot of things that
you don't
know have happened over this time even
if you were following closely
and some of those because i was saving
it along the way and doing
what we call in journalism embargoed
interviews where i would say
including to you okay i'm not going to
use this until spring of 2021 what are
you really thinking right now
but also uh i spent a lot of last year
pulling the reporting apart and going
back over it and then finding out a lot
of
details as a candidate i can tell you
that the spring of 2021 just seemed like
such an eternity away be like sure
i mean i remember you and i were after
the debate in atlanta which was
in november of 2019 we
rode i'm sure you don't really remember
this because you were probably in a
delirium
of uh of debate tonight but we rode from
the debate site to
an election or a debate night watch
party that you uh
were some of your supporters had thrown
and you showed up there
and i said to you okay so this recording
i'm not using any of it until it comes
out and you're like okay
yeah totally if it's after the election
at the time you're like whatever man
like you know
[Laughter]
and now i'm like curses
[Laughter]
um so that that must have been quite a
process
for you because you thought okay i'm
going to be
gathering all this information and a lot
of it's not going to see the light of
day
until afterwards it feels like this
is the first major work to come out that
documents
the 2020 democratic field um and i
learned a lot
reading this and i obviously was fairly
well attuned to a lot of it
being one of the candidates and even i
was like what
um wait where where some of the
conversations again it's really
impressive
how uh thoroughly sourced this stuff is
where
you you seem somehow privy to
conversations between candidate and
candidate
between candidate and their team um
certainly
uh some of it i know is because you're
in touch with people
who are affiliated with a whole variety
of candidates
so watching the field take shape i knew
that it was going to be very very
fragmented even when i was planning my
run in 17 i was like look
you had maybe a dozen republican
candidates uh the last time where it was
like an open field i said it's going to
be more like 20.
you were better than i was because i
when i thought it would be
a way to tell the story through the
candidates i my my ballpark was 16.
and we ended up with 26. these are
behind me is uh
all of the buttons from all the primary
candidates um there's 26 buttons in
there
and i should say this is yours
and that button i picked up uh on my
first reporting trip really for the 2020
race which was
a dinner the
iowa democrats dinner in october of
2018.
uh cory booker spoke there you did not
come but you there was a table that was
being worked by
some of your uh young staffers i think
carly
think carly riley was there yes carly
was there and and
uh there was a table for you and there
was a table for delaney and those were
the only two tables
now of course that dinner a year later
was like in an arena with a smoke
machine on the stage
and you know a production that had
15 000 people there or something um but
uh that event i thought that was the
first time that i was like oh he
like this guy who's been making noise
about running for president actually has
people who are
here supporting him and i grab that
button that is that's vintage
that button from that is a very
impressive display you have there
a button from each candidate is really
impressive you had to probably work for
a couple of them it ends with a bite and
then harris button
because i felt like it's all building to
it and then from the inauguration
[Music]
so
you tired of podcast advertisements
putting you to sleep
like this one then you should probably
get a helix mattress
no seriously i got a helix mattress six
months ago
and they advertise as and they tell me
to read that it's the best night of
sleep and the best mattress you'll have
but i'm be honest with you
they are not lying this mattress is
incredible so how it works is you go on
this quiz
on their website it takes two minutes to
complete and matches your body type and
sleep preferences
with the perfect mattress for you so
whether you like it soft or firm
or you sleep on your side or your back
you turn your neck you sleep hot or cold
there's a helix specific mattress for
each and everybody's unique
taste so we've got the helix lux model
and i got the uber like king size
mega thing um and i sleep on my side so
it's customized for that and i freaking
love it so it shows up super easy
comes in a small box it pops up it
inflates and it's the best night sleep
you're gonna have on a mattress it's
awesome so here's the deal go to
helixsleep.com and take their two
minutes sleep quiz
and right now helix is offering up to
200 off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners at helixsleep.com
yang that's helix hglix sleep.com
yang for up to 200 off and two free
pillows check it out right now
so the book is chock full of revelations
big and small um but i'm going to
to turn it to you what were the things
that
you found while you were covering
the race where you said ooh i'm gonna
keep that for the book
even though i kind of am tempted to
share it with people now like what were
like the
surprises that you saw um that
that uh you kind of held for publication
that everyone would have been excited
about at the time
uh well again some of this i knew
because i knew it and held on to it and
some of it i
only found out about early out because
i was reporting it on the these embargo
rules uh
and i think the best example is one of
the very first things that i
got that i knew would end up in the book
was
the scene that's in there of kamala
harris
uh deciding to run for president uh and
it's a meeting that she has in new york
uh with all of her campaign team and her
uh her sister uh who's her closest
advisor
uh and brother-in-law there uh and
they go through the presentations about
uh
fundraising and the schedule and how
it's all going to go
and uh and that's interesting in itself
but the moment
i just knew would be great to have is
she
it ends with a moot court because harris
really is like a lawyer
deep in how she thinks about things uh
and
so they have mark elias who's the
democratic lawyer
does a lot of election law challenges he
does the
uh case for running and uh
he does this whole big speech which ends
with him saying
the house of our democracy is on fire
and we need you to
be there okay then they turn to tony
west
uh harris's brother-in-law to do the
case against running
uh and because he's family they figure
he can go at her pretty hard
and he does and says she hasn't been in
the senate for long enough
and uh she uh
she was all these things she did as a
prosecutor were terrible
they were betrayal black people and
their betrayal progressives and
blah blah blah all things that ended up
being real factors during the campaign
for her
and he hits her hard and they're all
sitting there thinking like
oh [ __ ] glad glad he
uh as the brother-in-law braves all this
and
uh and she looks at him and she goes
yeah i like some [ __ ] up
and as i point out in the book she is
now vice president harris [ __ ]
is like her favorite word and she will
correct people if they put the r's into
it uh
so that's how she said it and what as i
was watching the attacks go on about her
record as a prosecutor
of course as a reporter you want to say
like i have this super juicy thing
and this is how she talked about and
this is how she dismissed it but i
couldn't use it
i'm glad that it was there for the book
um because i think it's interesting
even in retrospect and uh
and so that that really was
again that was i had a separate notebook
that i was keeping of
stuff that was for the book and that was
in the notebook by
january of 2019
um the whole scene of it um and
parts of it were in earlier uh there
were other things too
uh that uh that really surprised me i
mean i think one of the ones and because
it ended up being so relevant
also kind of relates to the vice
presidential process but knowing
just how
uh rough and vicious things got between
bernie sanders and elizabeth warren
and then knowing the story that's in the
book of how
warren once she decides to drop out is
stressing about what to do with her
endorsement
with the idea that she wants bernie
sanders to not be the nominee
and she wants joe biden to be the
nominee at that point and whether
for her the right calculated move is to
endorse
sanders so that she can have the
credibility to then call on him to drop
out a week or two later or whether it's
to endorse biden
um so that she can give him the
progressive boost
uh and in the end she didn't endorse
anybody she just
didn't make no decision but she's having
these like
conversations with her staff with other
people with barack obama it's all going
on
but when it comes time for the uh
biden to think about a vice presidential
nominee warren really wants it
and what would have really helped her at
that moment is bernie sanders saying
hey i think you should consider
elizabeth it would mean a big deal
a great deal to me to my supporters
would be
a way to draw everybody in and sanders
is so pissed about everything that went
on
that he won't say it and he won't say
he won't even bring up her name and he
kept on saying oh we're
you know when he was talking about it
and they were talking a fair amount um
he he would say oh well we're not i
don't bring up the vice presidential
stuff
and that's that was his uh way of not
uh saying anything good or bad about
warren because he didn't want to trash
her
but he could have helped her and he
decided not to and maybe
she would have been the vice
presidential nominee otherwise there
were some other concerns the biden team
had including
that she would make she would sort of
reinforce the idea that biden looked old
uh but um
that especially and and that stuff i
started to really
get a sense of uh during the vice
presidential selection process so that
was
over the summer i was doing some
reporting people would send me i can
tell you this part but you can't use
this until later
the bernie warren interplay was
fascinating in your book
like that there was a real blow by blow
even in the beginning
when they're each deciding to run
they're taking each other's temperature
that sounds fascinating and i've
obviously been around both of them but
you know
like a dozen times i've seen them
interact with each other
would you describe them as friendly
they just they're very cordial very
cordial colleagues
uh you know that they're uh you know
like there's definitely a high degree of
familiarity um i
i feel like the the warmth um
you know might have uh gone up and down
over the time
like
no but what you're getting at it like
that's it right and the chapter in the
book is called not friends the first
chapter about warren and sanders right
like
because they're not you'd think that
they maybe are but they're not
um and they're like
gaming each other out over the course of
2018 to see which one was going to run
for president
uh ultimately deciding
i don't care i'm running i don't care
what he does or i don't care what she
does i'm running
uh you know it comes to a head in a way
at this dinner that warren invites
sanders over to her apartment
in washington uh and like one of the
funny details in the book to me
is that sanders afterwards
uh would tell people that warren cooked
for him
and warren ordered in italian he said oh
she made lasagna for me
and like it was a much more significant
thing that happened at that
dinner that's the dinner where people
may remember it blew up later that
warren heard him say basically he didn't
think a woman could
win um he says that what he said about
it was that he was saying
it would be hard for a woman to run and
win
but even just at the deep details of it
of
uh like how these people relate to each
other but warren doesn't
she's not much of a cook um so
but sanders is assuming oh this italian
food that's here
she must have made it for me it was wild
for me isaac because like the first
couple of times i was around various
candidates like there were different
levels of uh
receptivity to me where initially
they just didn't know who i was
like that happened you know but but then
uh like over time they became familiar
with me and
uh you know there's like a degree of um
collegiality that would get built up um
but that i remember the first time i met
elizabeth warren i was in a room
and when you're a candidate there are
certain levels of energy around you
where like you come in a room and then
people really want to talk to you
uh and so the the first time i was in
the same room as elizabeth warren was
like a fairly big democratic event in in
one of the states i think it might have
been um
south carolina and then that like
all these people like flocked to her
because she was elizabeth warren and a
big deal and at the time i was not a big
deal
um and so candidates would like bigfoot
each other all the time that way
not intentionally necessarily they just
come in and everyone
here karen um and so like the first time
i was around
elizabeth uh she didn't really have much
uh who i was and i i think it was really
only after the debate started getting
going that
that that they would start to um pick up
on who some of the other candidates were
um but uh you know the watching people
interact with each other was fascinating
for me like it was for everyone else
uh where you'd see something going on in
the press and then you'd see the people
interact individually
well i feel like for you you had this
this strange experience where
you didn't know any of these people
beforehand so you were
sort of like a spectator of like getting
to know all these people like a lot of
america was
but on the other hand you were there you
were on the debate stage you were
in backstage at these events you were
because your candidacy was starting to
pull together and uh certainly i mean
like
when it became the moment when it became
clear to me that you were going to be
something that was a significant part of
the race
was the debate in detroit the second
debate
um when uh
i'm gonna get your exact phrasing wrong
but you there was a question about
climate change and you said well maybe
we need to consider moving a higher
ground right which was
this very uh in some ways dark
nihilistic way of looking at things but
also very practical minded because
your point was we spend a lot of time
talking about climate change and like
we're talking and talking talking and
the climate keeps changing right
and i think that the reaction that that
generated to me
uh was really fascinating um
and uh and i but it's still i think for
a lot of the other candidates
you were not it took a little bit longer
for them to plug into the fact that you
were this was
something that was really gonna catch um
and
uh but yeah i mean i had
talking to you along the way talking to
you for as we did a little bit for the
book um
i just think your perspective on it is
it's almost like
uh what it would have been if i could
have been backstage except
you know because because you had that
detention you know like i think when i
was a laborer i was the lay person
that's true i was a lay person being
like yeah this is interesting
[Laughter]
and you would get these fresh reactions
you know there's
a bunch of moments in the book you see
the people relating to each other
but they all know each other already and
they they kind of know uh what they like
about
each other and what they don't like
about each other uh and
uh and to you you could see them all
for the you know getting the first
impression of them and i think that
uh it's it's fascinating to me that what
you were able to
see of them and and uh and i know it was
frustrating to a lot of them
to see you take off in the way that they
that you did and that they didn't
well well well they were always like
that there was like a running joke
where um you know it's all fun and games
until andrew gang passes you in the
polls
it was like all of like all of the you
know the candidates that were
struggling to stay on stage you know i
think
i think my campaign was a source of
frustration uh to some of them and their
teams
um the people that were true contenders
what was funny is at
that detroit debate i had a bit of a
back and forth with elizabeth warren
about automation versus
versus regulation uh on on the loss of
manufacturing jobs in detroit and you
know i'd spent a lot of time
but like the the contenders wanted
absolutely nothing to do with me where
it's like that
in the sense that it's like any time i
spend having exchanges with andrew gang
is like lost time
you know what was it and i medicare for
all plays a pretty significant role in
the book just because i i
it became this defining thing in the
race
but now i've said this to other people
uh along the way uh
every single debate the first 20 to 40
minutes of it were about medicare for
all
and i don't think anybody could ever
really understand what anyone was
talking about it was only when it would
go to the other topics
that it seemed like you were actually
getting a debate you were seeing
what candidates were and what they
believed in i personally believe as a
political reporter
yeah look everybody spends a lot of time
in
debate prep that's part of running for
president even you did as a new
candidate right
uh and so you get used to what uh what
might come up and you think about what's
the smartest way to say it or this
you know this suavest way to say it uh
and for me as a political reporter what
i'm always interested in is how do
people respond when you throw a question
at them that they're not expecting at
all
like how do you see the thought process
and i think especially for president
because
uh so much
of the job of being president
is things that you could have never
anticipated
and so what i think people should really
think about when they're deciding
certainly within a primary is
watch the way these people think which
thought process which approach to this
uh
do is appealing to you because that's
what you're going to
get that's what you're buying when the
the time comes
yes i think that's one reason why people
were attracted to me in my campaign is
they like the process
they liked and the fact that half the
time i actually was answering with an
original thought because i had not
figured out what the uh politically
honed answer was
right no i mean i i mean i do think that
that's what it was i think that you see
the people who were you know
all everybody always spends a lot of
time in debate prep and it's so obvious
almost all the time to the reporters and
to the voters
uh that these are the prepared
responses and these are the lines uh and
occasionally one slips through that
seems authentic
uh and uh but isn't really
uh usually it's like a choreographed
event and that's less interesting to
people and i
i i wonder how much the takeaway from
what happened in the 2020 process
and who was interesting to people
as candidates you included again not
just you but
you were one of them uh who who was
not spending as much time thinking
through every response
so that every time it seemed boring and
then people kind of zoned out now
obviously it didn't work out for you in
the end so maybe
you know joe biden who spent a lot of
time in debate prep uh
but not rehearsing answers in quite the
same way that some of the other
candidates do
uh maybe maybe the lesson is to not do
it your way
but certainly for people who want to
jump forward
and be factors in the race you and
i think your campaign and buddha judges
campaign are the ones that were most
successful in doing things in a very
different way
from what anybody ever would have
thought possible i'm going to tell you a
debate prep story that might entertain
you isaac
apparently so i i think this is going to
make me sad that i don't have it in the
book probably
the people who were preparing me were
like hey you you keep answering the
question you get to spend too much time
answering the question
and it's not what you want to do because
my natural impulses to answer the
question you ask me a question i answer
it
and so i i said well
uh no like i feel like if i don't answer
the question it's kind of a problem
um and people can tell that they're like
no no no that's not right
and so what what they did was they they
had me listen to
bernie sanders answer a question um
without answering the question
um and it was about something like sex
ed i don't know like like in
in schools and then so they they had me
watch him uh answer with a non-answer
and i was like oh my gosh like he would
like and that's
that's when the light bulb went off for
me was when bernie like answered with
the non-answer and like what you know
what when the direction is talk filled
up the time and you know that like that
that was
uh the end of it uh so that was like a a
real
uh learning moment for me uh in debate
prep where
i realized what the um the right
approach is
for a lot of prepared candidates which
is you don't want to answer the question
nine times out of ten yeah and and
despite this coaching like i still try
to answer the question
[Laughter]
but i i had a much into trouble right i
mean it's like high risk high reward
right
um because sometimes you
uh not you generally sometimes you say
things that have gotten you into trouble
right um that like the phrasing is not
exactly
the right one and i guess the most
recent one with the mayoral campaign was
when uh you were asked about
homelessness and you said
the comment about mental health that got
some people riled up
i think that that uh
probably if you've done that a bunch of
times in debate prep your
campaign aides would have told you not
to say it that way but
also a lot of things that worked out for
you on the campaign
were things that probably more
experienced campaign aides would have
told you not to do
yes i believe you're right so the so in
your book i think some of the most
fascinating stuff really is the
interplay between
people that we all know well uh like
uh like elizabeth warren and bernie or
obama and bernie like holy cow like
that stuff i was like like
you know like wow um i i hadn't really
reckoned with the fact that
a lot of folks thought that bernie and
it
i guess it is true but like bernie
bernie's sticking around in 2016 may
have contributed to
uh trump defeating hillary uh
i think most people who know me well
know like i i was a burner in 2016. i
supported his campaign you know no but
mean i'm not sure about the timing
like you know it's like i don't know if
he should have folded up quicker but it
was fascinating to me that obama
seemed to be like very very like uh
after
bernie in terms of the timing of his
campaign this time around and that he'd
invested a lot of energy trying to build
that kind of relationship
yeah i i think obama has this role
throughout the book of uh
sort of being in a spot that where a lot
of democrats were
at each one of these moments right uh
and
he thinks the book starts on election
night 2016 with obama and biden watching
the
uh results as trump is winning and
trying to reckon with it
and up till that point
obama hadn't really wrapped his head
around the fact that trump could win
but he is in the final days of
campaigning thinking
what's going on and he had already been
a little bit um struck by
that clinton wasn't a good campaigner
and in his mind and that she
uh no matter what happens the bad stuff
uh
seems to stick to her and nothing none
of it was sticking to trump
so he's concerned about that but then he
does say i didn't i think bernie hurt
her more than we realized
which maybe is his rationalization of it
uh but i think a lot of people share
that uh
what i think obama does pretty
importantly
is when he starts to think about the
role that he's going to have
out of office for the democratic party
which is
to be more involved than he ever seemed
like he was
to most people um that one of his big
missions has to be to make sure that
bernie sanders
feels more a part of things than he did
in 2016.
and obama does that very basic way he
starts inviting him in for meetings
and phone calls and they talk they get
to know each other
there's a phone call that's recounted in
the book of
uh when obama first called sanders in
2016 and told him to drop out
he was on the golf course in florida
between
putts and he called and he was like you
got to drop out it's time
to go from that to inviting him to sit
in the office
and spend time there and go through and
talk about
lots of things back and forth
that's a big change and that has a lot
to do
i think with why sanders approached
this candidacy differently in in 2016
uh and uh and
oh sorry 2016 to 2020 and why
when it came down to why when it came
time to wind down the campaign
in 2020 that obama was able to step in
at that point and
talk to sanders and say listen bernie
like we got to figure out how to end
this
help me figure out what i can do to help
get you there
and standards is really receptive to
that and they work things out
uh but um
but that's because of the the time that
obama put in
to building that relationship up yeah
it's impressive to me that he
made that commitment well ahead of time
that it wasn't like a last-minute um
call and i had my call with obama
though that was uh after the fact
there wasn't
you were one of the few people that he
didn't talk to about getting into the
race because
um much like other democrats he would
not have thought to
speak to you beforehand but then yeah i
mean i think that's the point right is
that like
you made an impression on a lot of
people and by the end of it then he does
want to talk to you
so your book definitely paints a very
very
much more throwing complete picture of
uh what's going on with the candidates
and the campaigns and anything that has
existed heretofore certainly because you
know this relatively recent history
um and so anyone who was wrapped up in
this race
this is definitely required reading
battle for the soul
i gotta say when when um joe
joe and i like interacted any number of
times and for whatever reason
he and i spoke after or before each
other at a bunch of events
and joe would always go to this battle
for the sole narrative and i
wasn't really that into it at the time i
was like battle for the soul like what
the heck does that even mean
like a lot of people it's interesting
because um he
so that's a phrase that he starts saying
after charlottesville
in 2017 he writes an essay actually for
the atlantic
that that's in there uh and
uh and okay people are like yeah sure
whatever and then he kept saying it and
then uh i remember when he got into the
race
in 2019 it's uh
it's a little behind the scenes of how
things work for most campaigns not yours
because yours wasn't put together in the
same way but
uh most of the people who you would
think would run
the reporters would get a call a day or
two before
like okay guess what um i'm calling
because
tomorrow morning right now like just to
get you ready and it would be the
pressure and
okay like what's it and they would give
you the the talking points here are the
themes of the campaign
the funny thing for me is that i had
broken the story that biden was going to
run
about a week and a half before he was
officially announcing
and so then i got that call from someone
on his staff
uh the day before he was announcing and
i said oh yeah i heard that he was going
on and uh the person on the phone said
to me and so
um the themes were gonna be built around
the first one is the battle for the soul
of this nation
and i said okay you know what um it
seems
cliche at that point and then you know i
know from
reporting for this book that they would
do focus groups on it and people
said what are you talking about it
doesn't make any
sense uh and when i uh the book ends
with this interview that i did with
biden
uh it's just very touching the president
yeah
it's very touching it was
i mean like i said the book was uh
the last 50 pages of the book were not
expected to be there until
after it was supposed to be done and we
we spoke
uh on february 2nd it's the end of the
book
in part because the rest of the book was
already like getting fully edited at
that point in copyrighted and everything
and so it had to be the last thing but
it really
worked out in a sort of poetic way that
the book is in some ways the story of
how joe biden ended up in the oval
office and it ends with joe biden in the
oval office
and we had this conversation that i mean
look you've talked to him in a bunch of
things
he's a different person when you ask him
like okay what do you think the pay fors
are going to be about the infrastructure
deal
he'll give you one thing but if you
actually talk to him on a human level
you get a much different
person and a much deeper person
uh and we were there was like a little
chit chat at the beginning of the
interview
and i said to him um
so what's it like being in the oval
office every day and waking up upstairs
and he says to me well you know
i was in the oval basically every day
for eight years when obama was president
and and i've been here a lot so that's
not it waking up
upstairs uh you know there's some days
where i can't even find my clothes
nobody told me the moving was gonna be
part of this man and because
i'm a smart ass what i immediately
responded was
uh well you're the one who wanted this
job
and and he uh and he said to me yeah you
know someone said to me
[Music]
i'm like the dog that caught the car
after all this
and i i said no i'm the dog that caught
the bus
um and then uh he was starting to kind
of
go deeper in that and joe biden can
wander off in
directions of you know tangents of
conversation sometimes
and he knows me from covering him and i
know him
but i knew that now he's the president
and now there's a ticking clock
and so i only had so much time for this
interview and so i steered him back to
and i said so for this book that i'm
working on
uh like remember mr president this is
why we're talking
um uh we just we were playing around
with a bunch of titles through the very
end we just landed on it's going to be
called battle for the soul
so that's you know from you uh and
he said to me yeah you know the
difference between you and me pal is
i actually believe it
and i said no i think you you were
actually on to something
uh i don't think when he got into the
race he could have anticipated
anything like what his presidency is at
this point
um and all of these crises that are part
of it
but um it does
feel like between the pandemic and the
economic crisis and the racial reckoning
and the democrat the crisis of democracy
that we're in
it it is it's a question of what america
is going to be
and and this he was right i mean i i
could have you know
like i i was uh dubious in real time but
you know the man won in his president
and thank goodness for it
you know like even as someone who ran i
feel like the people
chose correctly uh that it was you know
that we needed to be joe to beat trump
uh he needed to
go to be president um
so again this book required reading for
anyone
who's uh who's into politics and
certainly anyone who's touching the 2020
race
um my my question now for you is kind of
forward-looking
like as someone who spent more time with
the the these people
um than just about anyone like what and
i'm enjoying the biden administration
let me say
like i i i think that got a lot of great
stuff done
and you know hopefully this
infrastructure package comes together a
bunch of other things happen
um but what do you think moving forward
like the democrats came out of the
wilderness and managed to beat trump
like you know fantastic and i'm not sure
if the republicans are in the wilderness
the same way you could definitely argue
yes you could argue
that there's still trump's party that it
may like someone asked me the other day
what's going to happen in 2024
and then the first thing i said was uh
biden trump too
like that that's the first thing that
came to my mind was like it's just going
to be a rematch and they looked at me
kind of aghast when i said this
but then i said it's like why would
trump not run again
uh and if you know if he's up for it and
then why would joe not run again
if he's up for it so i i anyway that
that's the first thing that
i said when someone asked me um do you
so not to necessarily say you have to
prognosticate that far ahead in terms of
24 but what do you see coming down to
pike as someone who's been
cataloging uh this process
well like the great lesson from 2016 for
me as a reporter is don't try to predict
what's going to happen
so uh when i was walking out of the
javits center on election night uh
leaving clinton's party
to take a train back to dc in the middle
of the night get to the white house
i've emailed a bunch of people who
worked for obama in the white house
and the subject line was just do you
have a plan uh
and there was nothing in the email and
only one of them came back to me and
said nope
um so that's why you don't make
predictions
uh i i don't
it's possible that it's going to be
biden versus trump again
and i don't know that we're prepared for
what that means
but i think that the
lesson from the riot and from
what has happened since then
is that this is still a very ongoing
thing uh that this is people who
want to say okay like
we we had the election in november 2020
and that's
and it was settled uh i think that you
see that feeling among
uh certainly a lot of liberals um
that like okay we like trump's gone
beat him um that sense has set in in
some ways even as trump has continued to
carry on
that seems very strange to me um and
uh but likewise i think for republicans
to look at this and to say
that they know what their party's
supposed to be and what it's going to be
uh is like they have no clue
it's really possible that
that trump will be the nominee again
but it's also really possible that it
could be someone else and potentially
someone
who is not so much like
trump whoever it is i think at some
point will have to have some level of
allegiance to trump
if it's not trump himself uh but the
point that i'm making is
i hope that part of the lesson of the
last
four or five years in this country is
that politics matters and government
matters and people should get involved
and see it as something that really
makes a difference in their lives and
the lives of people around them that
it's not just a game
and it's not just like the way that when
i was a kid i
like i said it was kind of sports to me
but then you have to fight for what it
is and i mean fight
not in a violent physical way but to
really be
part of it because and i i said this a
couple weeks ago on
uh to seth meyers that this is like the
end of the first star wars movie like
the death star is down
right like it was blown up uh but they
built another death star
you know um that that's the film right
um uh and and i
think that we are going through
so many changes as a society all at once
to think uh and again like
i'm gonna reference your candidacy but i
remember
standing at an event you were doing
in southeast iowa in january of 2020
that 120 130 people had showed up at
which was more than most of the
presidential candidates were getting at
that point
uh and you were doing your stump speech
uh about
uh then amazon doesn't pay taxes and you
see these strip malls that are decimated
that
automated trucking is coming and all all
of that
and the way people were plugging into it
then as a crisis
that was going on knowing it was
gnawing at all of us right what's
happening
and then it's just and there were other
things that that's true people saying
like
why can't i afford my mortgage anymore
why am i working so hard right
and and all of it obviously has been
accentuated by the pandemic
right and uh and then other things too
right like
the summer of protests last year after
george floyd was killed
that it's weird and
that that woke so many people up but it
did
including like there's a moment in the
book where joe biden is
like woken up by it um and he hears al
sharpton speaking
and sharpton says you know what all
black
people feeling me on their necks and
biden says i've never thought of it that
way before that's joe biden who
has been in public life for basically
ever
right um he first starts running for
office in 1970 he was the vice president
of the first black president he's done a
lot of stuff on civil rights
uh and he it it's all of this that we
just have to
put together and uh try to figure out
some way through so that the country
doesn't come apart
and it's on all of us it's on the
reporters it's on the politicians it's
on
uh but more than that it's on the voters
to tell us and the people to be voting
so that they are voters
what they want it to be because i think
that uh sadly
for too long in this country so much was
decided by
uh elections in which most people
weren't voting and so most people's
uh uh voices weren't being heard and
that creates
the these problems that were bubbling
under the surface that
end up exploding and a lot of what i got
into in this book
i love it isaac i agree that we have to
try to make it so more people are voting
uh one of the things i want to do is try
and make it easier to vote
uh in in ways big and small um
but certainly there's a lot at stake uh
one of the things that i feel is
is that there is like disintegration
versus integration
you know it's like things that are going
to tear us apart versus things are going
to pull us together
and the things that are going to tear us
apart in my mind are getting
stronger and clearer and the things that
are going to pull us together
are for the most part weakening like
most of the institutions you look up and
you say okay like you know what like
what what holds us together no like the
school board the pta
like my place of worship my block
association
you know like the um my friend group
uh family ties whatever it is like that
the things that
would keep us together are not
necessarily thriving
uh and you know like as we're losing
them we're not sure what replaces them
uh what one of my goals uh through my
campaign was
trying to come up with kind of a new set
of connections but it's
and like it's unclear uh so i'm with you
man
like um i asked you what comes next and
you were like hey
no like it's going to be very very hard
to know because you know you're right
like
there are a lot of forces at play and
who could have predicted
uh where we are now x years ago heck
even andrew yang who was like
all about it was like could not have
been like yeah there's going to be this
you know i mean i wasn't talking large
scale pandemic i was
talking about right but
right like you asked me about when this
book started the proposal that i wrote
in 2018
says something like uh that this is
going to be the craziest election ever
in 2020
um and probably the most important in
american history
and that was before i knew any of what
2020 itself would hold
and how much it ended up playing into
things uh and so
it also tells i think about what what
we're set up for here
what is this democratic party that
exists and what does that mean for
people who are democrats and what does
that mean for people who are republicans
and what does that mean
for people who are neither and trying to
figure out okay well which one do i vote
for because i don't want to really be a
part of either them
what is what does that churn look like
and uh now of course a lot of the story
ends up being about
what is this interplay between
progressives and modern
whatever that means i think progressive
is a word that we have completely lost
track of whatever definition it's going
to happen that's a conversation you and
i have had separately but
um all of that uh like
the book ends and it's not like okay so
uh you know roll the credits and that's
it um
everything is fine and done and neatly
wrapped up
uh it ends uh with this
is like okay so this is where we are now
let's see what happens
it ends with joe biden talking about the
fourth industrial revolution
[Music]
yeah he does he does he says
he says to me that if he gets it when he
gets out of the white house
that's he's going to write a book about
that and i didn't at that point want to
interrupt him and say
you know andrew yang actually wrote that
book
i joe and i have had half a dozen
conversations about the fourth
industrial revolution he's really after
it
um but i i was kind of glad that that
was one of the notes that he
he ended on um congratulations on an
awesome awesome work
uh isaac um you know that the book is
your first book it's not gonna be your
last because i know that they're gonna
like people are gonna want you to do it
again i know you're like oh no doing it
again
um and have people already been in touch
with you about the film rights is this
gonna end up like
uh some some uh like docuseries and hbo
any of that jazz um
there there's been a a couple of
conversations but nothing
uh that's done yet so we'll see
hopefully it all happened that'd be
great
um i do think that um
so much of this election like
we haven't processed yet what happened
because it was like just so crazy with
trump
all the time trump right uh and for most
people that's all that they could take
in
and to realize that there was this whole
other story
that was going on at the same time which
i actually think and
then obviously wrote a book about it but
in some ways it's more interesting
because it was less predictable
of how it was going to go trump to me
always felt like yeah he's going to say
the craziest thing possible okay
um uh and so uh so we'll see
but uh certainly no film rights have
been sold yet uh hopefully they
they will be then my film producer
friends you can still get in on this you
gotta call
isaac i i will even agree to play myself
look at that oh there you go
what candidate already passed um but
if you're listening to this or watching
this uh battle for the soul by edward
isaac dover
uh master work on the 2020 race from the
democratic side uh congratulations on
this man
uh really uh it's a massive achievement
thank you thank you and thanks for
having me on
no problem you can also check out isaac
at the atlantic
uh he's on social media on twitter uh
but he he's one of the people i turn to
to see what the heck is going on out
there
in the in in the political universe and
the real world
uh you can trust this man i do
thank you
you